I'm doing one thing really stupidly that
I should stop doing it's like how long
is it gonna take you to figure out what
that is it's about two seconds right
you've known it forever and you could
even make it less demanding you could
say there are some stupid things that
I'm doing that I know are stupid and
wrong that I could stop doing that I
would stop doing and then you can just
start with that and you can just do that
and maybe it's just a little thing
although it's not because it's it's a
it's a step forward on the proper voyage
it's not a small thing and you think
well what would happen you could say
let's do this for a year even a month
just try not to do things you know to be
stupid and wrong for a month and that
means not to say things you know to be
stupid and wrong as well maybe that's
the most important thing just do it as
an experiment see what happens and so
fun because I have people writing to me
from all over the world who are saying
they're doing that they're saying well
you know I cleaned up my room and and
then I stopped saying stupid things and
oh my god it's like things are way
better it's like who would have guessed
it you know and so it's low-hanging
fruit man because they're saying that's
the only thing if there's a lot of
things wrong with you then it's it's
really easy to start fixing it you know
you got so much there's so much
territory that you can inhabit I will
make of thee a great nation I will bless
thee that's good I mean the whole nation
thing that's positive but to have God on
your side that's you know you might want
that when things get rough that would be
good and make that name great and thou
shalt be a blessing wonderful that's a
good deal then I will bless them that
bless thee that's good too and curse him
that curseth thee and in thee shall all
families of the earth be blessed
that's something that's something it
wouldn't be something if you could wake
up and your day was composed in part of
people thanking you for all the good
things you've done in the world wouldn't
that be good it's not impossible for
that
happen so Abram departed yes as the Lord
had spoken unto him and Lord went with
him and Abram was seventy in five years
when he departed out of her and that's
all
now Abraham lives a long time but this
is also part of this story so he has a
wife who can't have children he has
nothing obviously he's been hanging
around dad's Shack for a little too long
given that he's 75 right it's time it's
time to get a fire lit underneath him a
bit and so he's not got much going for
him but he still decides to to move
forward and I've seen this too you know
like if you don't have your destiny in
hand by your time you're 30 it's it's
rough you start hurting and if you don't
have your destiny in hand by the time
you're 40 then you really start hurting
and forties a real fork in the road the
fork in the road that's always where you
meet the devil by the way and that's
because every time you have to make a
decision the possibility of evil beckons
that's why that is I had a friend I've
told you a little about him and he
killed himself just after 40 you know he
had had a book published it was a very
small press he was quite a good writer
but he could not get himself together
and it hit him too hard at 40 and I'm
not saying that it's hopeless at 40 I'm
not saying that and I'm not saying that
partly because of these verses but also
partly because of what I've seen in my
clinical practice I've had people come
to me who have had very chaotic and
ill-spent lives let's say who were in
that neighborhood of age and and it's
true for people who are older as well
who then decided to make a real effort
and to try to make where they were
better you know instead of being bitter
about where they weren't because that's
the bitterness that really does you in
it's really not good it's the opposite
of gratitude it's it's it's the
manifestation of resentment it makes you
malevolent it's very very bad to be
bitter it's not it's not it's hell to be
bitter and if you're 40 and you're not
successful then you have to accept your
lot and you have to start to improve
what's right in front of you and if you
do that it doesn't take very long it's
quite interesting to watch people things
can be a lot better in six months and
they can be way better
two years like it's a struggle uphill
struggle but it's by no means impossible
and and I don't know again what the
limit of that is I suppose it depends to
degree to some degree on the degree of
your commitment but anyway so a
brocation of the the real validity of
this story God isn't setting this up to
be easy right
Abraham's old and and his and his wife
is all too and more than that she's
barren how is he going to be the father
of nations how is he going to be
successful well the initial departure
point is insufficient radically
insufficient and and that's very
inspiring because it means that you can
start from where you are